[Applause]
yes happy Monday more like happy
Funday I just invented that word so
Friday the Daily Caller obtained video
of a US Senate employee having an Al sex
inside a historic Senate Judiciary
Committee hearing room oh Applause thank
you Pro anal sex in the Senate Judiciary
room audience but we don't have access
to the video so we had Jean one of our
producers sketch a screen grab there you
go yeah talk about yielding the floor to
the next
gentleman now after the story broke
Democrat Senator Ben carden's office
released this statement quote Aiden ma
sopy is no longer employed by the US
Senate well good thing his ID badge had
a picture of the back of his
head Security Forces tell Fox News that
Capitol Police are taking the matter
seriously and charges haven't been ruled
out now either this was a rare event or
maybe this year's Secret Santa gift
exchange got way out of
hand but where else can you get paid to
have sex in the workplace with a free
call
oscopy only in DC are the AIDS so
helpful they'll bend over backward and
forward for
you I don't even feel dirty now
predictably the ex-staffer responded by
claiming that the outrage is homophobia
quote I have been attacked for who I
love to pursue a political agenda he
even states that he'll
be even States he'll be exploring his
legal
options
exploring not the best ver verb so he's
La lering up and I guess we're all
supposed to be scared well let me be the
first to say up
yours too
late but it's what liberals never
understand it's not the what it's the
where the sex tape was filmed in the
same spot where the 911 Commission had
its hearings where Supreme Court
justices have been confirmed so yeah
it's not about the sex act it's where it
occurred you want to put on a Scooby-Doo
costume and be walked on a leash by a
guy dressed like genas Khan fine we've
all been
there I mean we have haven't we but do
it at home and if you're going to get
filibustered over a senate conference
table at least use a
coaster Now NBC wants to make this all
about conservative outrage we're not
outrage but hell fine we'll take it at
least we're standing up for something
your right to be yourself doesn't confer
more rights on you than the rest of us
have nor does it gain you extra
privilege for whatever behavior in fact
I know some people who got 20 years for
trespassing in that building and unlike
the Senate a those guys got screwed in
the
capital right in the
Rotunda which is not a
euphemism so welcome to the real world
where your equal rights also mean the
equal obligation to behave responsibly
and also equal opportunity to be be made
fun of cuz the jokes here are just too
easy I mean just mentioning you at a
staff position makes me want to pause
and smoke a
cigarette talk about a joint
resolution I'm against that motion
proceeding after all that's one small
caucus but is that a veto or some guy
named
veto sorry now if you haven't seen the
video Let's just say it doesn't leave
much to the imagination I haven't seen
that much crack since I took that trip
to the Liberty
Bell but I do fear that the hearing room
is forever
tainted but the only real mystery is
who's the other man if he's Republican
then they took Reaching Across the aisle
a little too
far if he's a Democrat we can only guess
of course over in the house we know that
Jamal Bowman has a thing for violating
exits whoever it was the point is that
for the left it's never just about
expanding rights and privileges it's
also about destroying the borders that
separate behavior and it's always done
with a sort of mission creep you know
we're not supposed to notice the slow
erosion like having adult material in
school libraries or Marxist dance troops
in the White House videos or Jesse
Waters
hairline but this is a white house uh
that had Dylan volan interview Joe Biden
a fake version of Audrey heper
interviewing a fake version of a
president but he probably thought it was
Audrey heer and since he can't tell a
staircase from a water
slide no wonder his Supreme Court
nominee couldn't tell us what a woman is
he can't either meanwhile statues of
Washington and Jefferson are being torn
down because you see
that's inappropriate yeah if only they
were banging each other then they'd be
everywhere you're not going to get that
on Special
Report since then this white house has
seen cocaine drops a trans activist
Flash in her breast on the lawn e klepto
in charge of nuclear waste and then this
year's Christmas video featuring
anti-white cop hating commies all on
your dime yeah there's no sex in that
video the only ones getting screwed are
the taxpayers but wasn't it supposed to
be Trump that was going to violate the
decorum of the office remember how they
mocked Melania for blood red trees and
Donald for serving fast food to athletes
and the Dems you know they're the ones
who were supposed to restore decency
like when they excluded Hunter's baby
from the family Christmas stockings yeah
they left her out but their dogs got
stockings I guess those muts earned it
for taking the blame every time there
was an accident on the on the White
House carpet
the takeaway the left Cesar mission is
fighting the oppressors and destroying
Traditions without knowledge of either
and one's identity becomes a protective
shield for any idiotic Behavior but
there's a reason legislative buildings
and Cathedrals don't look like the
Playboy Mansion they're supposed to
represent something sacred and exalted
that governs human behavior and then the
Dems show up and the destruction begins
drag queens and kids schools and
libraries men and women's Sports Tap
dancing totalitarians in the white house
but recording a sex tape in the Senate
may be the dumbest thing that's ever
been done there and Cory B Booker works
there these kids need to learn that it's
not all about them and their need to
celebrate themselves the State Building
belongs to the American people it's ours
not yours and really don't film anal sex
in a senate judicial hearing room if you
don't want to be judged
so let's keep that room porn free just
like we're keeping two genders in
Christmas to whoever slides down your
chimney is none of our business and we
intend to keep it that
way perod let's welcome tonight's guest
for a guy named hert he's easy on the
eyes Fox News contributor Charlie
h he's a Bigfoot Enthusiast because like
his fans no one's ever seen one of them
either oh comedian Jeff
D he's the only attorney general who can
deadlift a Honda former active attorney
general Matt
Whitaker and O zic hired her to be an
after photo New York Times bestselling
author and Fox new contributor cat
[Applause]
Tim
so Charlie it's not just Israel flooding
tunnels I just want to tell you our
audience is so uncomfortable right now
so good your audience your audience is
yes um I just want come on you know how
slow news is but up to Christmas this is
like a gift from God thank you
God for this for this God did this God
did this he said God was like the gutf
show has been strugg Ling with news
let's give him a sex
tape but this is this is a little bit
too on the nose yes it is for a Gutfeld
and when and when it when it broke on
Saturday over the weekend the first
thing I thought was oh my goodness and
then the second thing I thought was oh
my goodness Monday night's Gutfeld show
is going to be the first time he gets to
talk about this and I'm going to be
sitting right here yes and this is why I
got into the newspaper business because
I wanted to sit here on National
and talk about this with you but I have
to say that your your monologue was like
it was absolutely Shakespearean it was
it was I mean the not that like uh you
know it was hard to find the double on
handras but they were but they were
there and you tuck I think you tucked
them into at least three or four into
every yeah so I slip them in so to speak
yeah and uh all of this happened uh like
at the very spot where uh Amy kichar yes
interrogated the future Supreme Court
Justice about his boofing and uh beer
drinking you know practices back in
college you also made a very important
point I think I I feel like genuinely
sorry for this kid I mean this kid has
been led to believe by sort of the left
that uh that you have the that he has
like this magic Cape around him and he
can do whatever he wants and it doesn't
matter and it's not going to come he
found out that the magic Cape doesn't
work it doesn't make him invisible he
found out the hard
way
[Laughter]
yeah
Jeff is this worse than January
6th it is in my opinion yeah for sure uh
I agree with him that was that opening
was so good 22 if you're keeping count
of butt humping double
on which I'm a fan of that's pretty cool
now this whole story is a pain in the
ass and uh
25 no uh I'll be honest when I heard
that a staffer had uh sex in the Capitol
hearing room I was like this guy rules
yeah that was my instinct I was like
what this is pretty awesome this is like
my type of politics you know this is
cool uh but then I was annoyed that then
then he started to complain that the
public uh opinion was homophobic that's
where he lost me right just double down
it be like yeah I did a thing man you
don't hook up at work like this is edgy
this is good but then for him to
complain that it's homophobic I'm like
what are you doing yeah it's not
homophobic this is a natural reaction to
you being this gratuitous at work and
getting caught it's like someone like I
don't know looting a store and then
getting in trouble and then blaming
racism you know that never happens yeah
all right Matt uh how uncomfortable are
you feel oh I'm tremendously
uncomfortable I always think about you
when we're doing these topics it's like
how can I make you Grimace even more
okay well I will try to cover my facial
expression
now what do you make of this story I
mean we have to be very careful about it
but uh what do you think of the overall
what's your overall take my overall take
is unlike you know the comedy here I
think this is sort of a serious thing I
mean there you know just there a
complete erosion of decorum and decency
and respect for our institutions but
it's to to your point it's just this
victimhood it's this you know the
somehow I did something wrong but I'm in
a protected class and so I can you know
I'm the victim of some right-wing it's
it's like we don't care nobody cares
it's where it's it's the it's the lack
of respect and the you know defiling of
you know what should be a fairly
respected place that's what that's what
I and again that's you know that's this
is as I was coming into this kind of
like Charlie I was fearful Greg of being
on the show and talking about this topic
so so I'm going to throw it back to you
okay you you handled that quite well
that was quite a tight rope
professionals handle this can we blame
like cat think about the mile high club
do you think that this could that be
people always trying to find adventurous
places to do things so they can tell
about brag about it I'll started with a
mile high club I blame Orville
Wright yeah that is his name the
homophobia is where he loses me too yeah
because what is he saying when he's
homophobic like I hope that you keep up
this energy when it's straight
Republicans doing anal in the Senate
Office and filming it like no because
it's not a thing that happens this is
the thing that this to my knowledge no
one else has done this right I don't
think so okay all right that's what I
thought and also like how would you feel
if that was your office yeah exactly I
often thought about that like do have
people done things in my office when I
got
there oh yeah you know it when you're
the boss you know it we judge it pretty
harshly it's not like Bill Clinton
recorded
it all right we got to move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else